wendy williams we have your first look
at her revealing new biopic
wendy williams is not going anywhere
i am going to tell it like it is it will
floor you you will laugh you will cry
you'll be like
well damn wendy how you doing oh wendy's
upcoming lifetime movie
and documentary both go there
long before she made headlines for
fainting on live tv
wendy became infamous on the radio you
have had some moments
that have become like pop iconic
moments interviews like the wit the
whitney thing
i gave it up did you go deep into it you
talk you let
oh really so whitney are you still using
drugs
is there drug use going on at this
present time who are you talking to
to you whitney january 30th 2003
wendy laid into whitney houston who
called into her radio show
and became combative now you're not
talking to me i'm a mother you ask me
like i'm a child
i'm a child wendy those things are being
addressed
as well as things that you never knew
about me wendy's always been open with
e.t
and as an executive producer on the
movie which stars the oval actress
sierra payton as williams
wendy doesn't shy away from the darkest
moments in her life
like a past drug battle you're
narcissistic you got a coke habit
i lost over a decade of my life
being hooked on cocaine then there's her
now ex-husband kevin's
frequent cheating even while wendy was
pregnant
infidelity does not always mean you
throw it out and sometimes it can
strengthen relationships
he's having a baby with her last year
after discovering he was having a love
child
wendy divorced kevin who was at the time
a staffer on her show
let's get me legally and financially
free from kevin hunter not you
nor anyone else have the power to take
away my gifts
i'm getting used to life as a single
woman again
i was involved with him for over 25
years i have
options out the wazoo that i did not
have
back then and and i have
clarity like i've never had before